you just have to get creative about it
it's one way doesn't work don't keep
doing things the same way 20 different
approach Holly you know made portfolios
and Mark Foley knows marketing her the
recognition she she deserved so she
started making life-size but she started
making Ryan cocktail it's all about you
know being creative never give up on
your dreams Oh see that world I
completely agree yeah I mean keep trying
keep doing different approaches never I
mean never give up even more and
sometimes through your dreams you might
find something that you like even more
so that's I mean you might even get a
new path that you're even happier with
so it's you know I started wanting to be
an ornithologist I'm definitely not
Norma tholla gist right now right yeah
that's what I heard of study of birds
and I have a degree in medieval history
which I don't use it all but I just you
know there's things that I'm passionate
about things that i love but the path
that I've come on is really what I've
truly you know found myself and that's
really what people need to strive for
she uses her medieval history degree to
make monster even if you don't know it
you're you know your path is still going
to be useful
one to show my brother you know follow
your bliss or something you know what
whew yes you do this might be a little
long for a bumper sticker funnel if you
have a passion to make sure that wearing
and run doesn't make you uncomfortable
oh my actually I am big I would have to
say I'm a fan base in seducer I did a
movie in the 80s homers genius
you